I I look at people in Hollywood I think
they're a little haunted by their good
fortune so they're trying to legitimize
themselves now by being you know
professorial and I've got some wisdom
here and your things you're the fifth
lead on full house
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special with our
guest Dennis Miller Dennis by the way is
the host of the Dennis Miller option
which is available for free you can
listen or subscribe at Apple podcast
Google podcasts wherever you get your
podcasts on the Westwood one podcast
network we'll start talking to Dennis in
just one second but first can you
believe it's already April time has a
habit of getting away but if you've got
a mortgage or kids or anyone depending
on your income you're gonna have to
spend some of that precious time at
getting a life insurance if you need
life insurance but you don't want to
spend a lot of time comparing it you
should give policy genius a try
policy genius is the easy way to buy
life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers and find the best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape no Commission's no hidden fees
just more time saved for you and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also do home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance they're
your one-stop shop for financial
protection so be an adult go get
yourself some life insurance right now
if you need life insurance but you're
short on time head to policy genius.com
and compare quotes policy genius is easy
it saves you money not to belabor the
point but it is indeed fast go check
them out policy genius spend less time
comparing life insurance more time doing
literally anything else again it doesn't
take a lot of time you just need to go
and get it done because you don't want
to be buried in a pauper's grave or
leave your family bereft if god forbid
something should happen to you is just
part of being a responsible adult the
best place to get any of these types of
insurance go and check out policy
genius.com right now that's policy
genius where you can spend less time
comparing life insurance and more time
doing literally anything in the world
else other than that policy genius.com
check them out well Dennis Miller thanks
so much for showing up to the Sunday
special you look surprised to be here
what about Walsh episode and why well I
just I didn't know enough about him I
hear his name come up but I also wanted
to see the lay of the land and it was
beautiful because he was so heartfelt
about his religious beliefs and when he
would lean in to make a point to you one
of these heat lamps over his head would
perfectly frame his head like a halo
speaking in and cyclical that laugh
right there would just frame his head
perfectly so for people who have fallen
out of touch with you what have you been
doing lately I want to go back all the
way in a second to the beginnings of
your career from birth to now yeah so
get the whole life story but what
you up to these days I go out on the
road and do my stand-up I just did a
special called fate news real jokes that
was my ninth special I go out with Mark
Steyn periodically we got and have it's
a little less comedy but it doesn't turn
into a think piece either it's kind of
funny but we take questions from the
audience than that but as far as a
television show I I live up north and I
don't I'm not exactly in demand now
anyway so sort of dovetails at 65 years
old I'm not one of these people who
always wanted to hustle it into the barn
I work hard my whole life I'd like to
travel a little I'm trying to read
everything that PG Wood has wrote and
that that's the task in itself and I
like to go hiking in that so when people
say to me not what are you doing now
it's enjoying the fruits of busting my
tail in the mining town that is
Hollywood for the last 35 years so quick
question about that specialist officials
great I watched it last night actually
and Montagnard on in demand well you
know what you can do the thing about
your political beliefs but I don't I
think that sounds whiny you you make a
choice to talk out loud and let the
chips fall where they may
if I had to say I'm 60 I'm 65 I don't
want to bang that drum again but did you
I mean who gets really and frequently
you know do you get super hot when
you're 65 years old I've had a beautiful
run I think things are in a suitable day
new mall it's not like it's not like I
can't do anything but I had my choices
are limited to some degree but it seems
to me that it's completely where it
should be like I said what do I have in
common with a 65 or with a 25 year old
kid you know what if I sit down with
many 25 year old kids who are friends of
my sons and they're all so nice but when
I watch somebody like a a OC abbreviate
the I guess that's the new lexicon but
when I watch her I think well this is so
obviously killing for but they're
enamored of her
vivacity the factual use social media
it's not a fact-based exchange they have
with her they just like the fact that
she's flipping the table on the old
school so I get all that and I think
well why would I appeal to them I don't
want to be the buzzkill that comes in
and you know does that you know Falcon
and the snowman discussions were you
know between the dad and the kids where
you're fighting with them closet
don't you say they shouldn't see it that
way so I'm about where I should be at
sixty-five I don't want to turn this
into sort of a nostalgia player you
grousing about the young but I look at
AOC in the same way that I look at some
of the comedian's the that I see working
today and that is enthusiasm over skill
do you get that impression also that
there's a real draw toward the
enthusiastic and the authentic as
opposed to the craft like actually
working through things
well the craft I think is oh listen
there's some guys are beautiful
technicians and they literally would do
syllable counts and peel it back but
something the main directive obviously
the company's always been getting laughs
now you can go out and do it in a myriad
of ways their physical comedians their
you know intellectual comedians you see
some guys anything wow that's so smart
but for the most part it's all about the
prime directive of getting laughs I've
noticed the change is more tectonic in
that it's turned everybody's comedy act
almost into an impersonator act like
Impressionists used to do they go what
if Jack Nicholson was working at the
Burger King and I was always Bridal I
had that I lacked that gene where I
could go with that where I'd say time
out he's one of the highest-paid actor
but they do it and then at the end
people applauded and that's sort of what
humor is now like people will make a
bold statement and get applause instead
of big laughs that's weird to me it's
sort of a short-circuited the primal
thing that it's an involuntary gesture
where somebody says something funny and
you don't have to intellectualize it you
just find yourself and that's the cool
part of it now it's people going hmm
and that's a big change for comedy
though the term that I've heard used
about this is clapped
that people are not actually laughing
anymore they're just there they're
clapping and this is the Hannah Gatsby
version of comedy where you have think
pieces now about why for thousands of
years we've actually been getting the
entire concept of comedy wrong it's not
that we're supposed to laugh at things
it's supposed to if we laugh at things
it's actually bad we're supposed to
think about things and then the thinking
is the humor it seems to me that we are
reshift entire nature of humanity around
what a bunch of very politically driven
people wanted to be because I mean I'm
old enough to remember when Jay Leno was
on television and trying to be funny and
now you've got people on TV in late
night who I don't even know if they're
trying to be funny anymore
I mean legitimately I think that Fallon
may be the only late-night host is even
making an occasional attempt to be funny
I don't know what your opinion is of the
party he's a great entertainer and I
like that about him I I think that you
have to understand if you want to at
some point you would lose those jobs if
you look look how good Jimmy is at it
Jimmy Fallon I I've been on Jimmy Kimmel
he was nice to me so I know I don't have
an axe to grind there I disagree with
him on many things but he's also a droid
at it and it's in his own way but
Jimmy's the entertainer to me look how
much trouble he got in for a simple hair
fluff with Donald Trump it's almost over
for him at that point really he's had
the rally and there is an individual's
choice at some point to keep a great job
now listen you can say you should make
her statement you should speak your mind
if you're a 45 year old Jimmy Fallon it
seems like a delightful guy the times
I've met him over the years good kid
makes me laugh off stains deadly funny
he's got the catbird seat he hosts what
Johnny Carson is they didn't make him
leave from New York he's loves New York
he's probably knocking off 30 to 30
million dollars a year or all win and
they say to it well listen no more Pro
Trump stuff or we're gonna this is the
they won't even state it but it's right
the old mob hit movies where they
compartmentalize it they'll have to deal
with you with extreme prejudice
you would eventually not have that gig
it's it's just the truth you couldn't go
out Jimmy could not go out there now and
espouse anything on that side I think at
that point it's what would Deion Sanders
whenever he does NFL football somebody
won't like
stretch out for a pass don't like short
ARMA they don't get lit up and Deion
Sanders you know business decision and
that's the purest thing of at some point
you have to understand the hierarchy
would whack you if you went out every
night and did a function and this is
where I feel like contrary to your own
perception of yourself I think that
there probably is a growing market for
somebody like you actually saying things
that are both funny and somewhat
conservative simply because if you look
at Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy like I I remember
when he used to do the sports thing on
Kevin and bean on 106.7 out here and was
you know a funny guy and when he was
doing his show with Adam Carolla and
Comedy Central and the humor came first
and now he's the Pope of late-night
right he gets up there and he's gonna
rail about Obamacare and and cry on TV
about Obamacare and I just think to
myself well isn't like where's the other
side of this equation where every funny
comedian seems to be being read out and
if you are moderate that's not enough
you have to at least make overtures
toward being politically woke if you're
going to survive in this way even guys I
like like I think John Mulaney is really
funny I think Mulaney he will have to at
some point in his show just dump on a
certain portion of the country so that
he can get his whoa cred in order so
that he can go about doing his normal
business well I mean isn't that leaving
half a box for a cloaking mechanism if
he doesn't everything else in his act
will be shot through the prism of is he
not woken up so yeah is it easier to
screw it throughout so you look for an
hour and you're doing some type of jokes
or is it better just in the middle like
a sorbet you cleanse your palate with
just good lot with a thing and hold him
to put your Trump with horns on the
track you can work both ends of that but
in the middle you've laid it's it's it's
odd to me how the the you it's demanded
that you establish that I I won't do
that there are times I think Trump's a
buffoon there are other times I think
Trump's great at what he does he's an
infinitely better president in my eyes
than he was a host of The Apprentice
there were times I'd watch him on the
apprentice and saying this is so stilted
and weird and awkward it
druvan but there are days I watch them
on as the president and I think well you
know when I see those Union guys being
led into the Oval Office and him just
saying God take some pictures and the
guy starts crying thinking about his dad
who's this
you know the boiler maker who never got
anywhere near that I always think wow in
an odd way the most patrician of these
guys I shouldn't say Patricia but the
billionaire guy comes in and he has a
stranglehold on what the hoi polloi mean
I'm fascinated by that I think it was
all those years of him in a hard hat
walking through construction sites with
the power tie on but he also has to
cohabitate with all these cats who were
throwing the building out for he has
nothing something gave him these
proletariat chops which I admire about
him you know whenever they say I just
this morning Ben I should let you ask
questions about ya rant here but uh I
was saw again this morning that a couple
of Democratic candidates Castro I forget
his name as a Julian Castro
Julian Castro and somebody gets that
Trump reminds them of the Third Reich
yeah bait oh yeah bait on I always look
at this stuff and I think for God's
sakes do you not see that you're not
being clever about how you're playing
this guy if you do hate them if you do
hate what he wants if you want him out
to throw down the Hitler thing and then
here's even the back-up plan on that
they if you say well listen when you say
he's Hitler like obviously my flash card
in my head is the systematic liquidation
of six million of his fellow human
beings I haven't seen anything like that
from chop and they'll say oh of course I
didn't mean that
and you'll say well what other Hitler
peccadillo you know the shitty mustache
the bad housepainter reviews on Angie's
List of course when you say so and again
this morning even today you've got a
bait or works positing himself as a
young hipster a young hipster does not
come in and say the man in the Oval
Office right now to me it's such an
overwrought word clumsy overplays is
like it's like Adolf Hitler it's so
stupid to me so I think when you say
eventually people will come around III
think that they might have to
because the I always think they have to
come out of this fevered state where
they go wait if I went beat this guy I
got a cut stop giving him freebies by
calling him Adolf Hitler and any proves
himself not Hitler and other people vote
for I mean this has been kind of my view
of what this political moment originally
was in the first place wishes they
called Mitt Romney Hitler I mean Joe
Biden went out there and suggest the
Mitt Romney the most anodyne human being
who has yet to walk the earth was going
to put black people back in Chains and
then I think the Republican Party and a
lot of people in middle the country that
you said you know what giant middle
finger well in China middle think with
orange hair let's do this thing man and
they just voted for Trump in the
primaries as that and that's the moment
we live in one with mitt wouldn't step
up do you how unrequited people felt
even if they liked them they thought
well listen I have this guy over for a
toddy but for God's sakes you're gonna
need a doc fighter in there remember I
look back at Mitt Romney and I think I
remember him saying that our biggest
geopolitical threat was Russia it's so
funny to me that Obama did the hipster
thing it's in June 1998 Cold War II he
wants it's you know ridiculing this man
and then the moment five minutes after
Trump won that election and they're up
in that they can't believe it up in
Hillary land they immediately trigger
the doomsday machine which just rushes
back blame Jim for Russian I thought it
is so crazy how they shift those things
I I keep waiting for a younger candidate
on the Democratic side to be hip enough
to come out and deny all the over plays
and establish himself somewhere in a
minute it's it's such an easy sister
souljah moment to come out on a couple
of these things for beta O'Rourke just
just step up and say obviously he's not
Adolf Hitler here's what he is and you
know lay out a few things that they have
problems with I can't believe that that
shows me how threatened they are on that
side that nobody can see that play
maybe this I don't even know how to say
is they booty jesh yeah yeah he's been
the only one who's made maybe he he sees
it and thinks geez I can go from mayor
president cuz there's a whole big
probably forty five percent that are
predisposed to go directly against Trump
in this next election
you got a new I don't even know if
there'll be a third party that probably
will be but you probably have to nibble
add six percent max or 5.1 percent max
or if there's a third candidate you
might not even have to get the fifty
somebody should be smart enough to years
out to say I got a disengage myself from
this pack that is over playing their
hand with Trump and look like the person
that the moderates will vote for because
I do think 45 or vote in forum 45 or not
voting for him and you get to start
making sense to those ten and I don't
think you're making sense to him
overplay in your hand with Trump
especially when the jobless claims to
what 49 year lows and but you know for
me a big thing and I always hear it I
don't hear it hit enough is there were
missiles flying over Japan from that
nutcase around two years ago testing
them it any at any point is he lobbed
those one could have blown up over Japan
you've got war war three yeah I almost
have to start it the fact he's not
testing him anymore is a huge thing
those are sitters at the net that unwise
moderate Democrat would step in and
start a sentence by saying here's what I
like about Trump and then and this is
the shorter part of sense rights all
you'd have to do if you were moderate
diamond but do that and boy I'm telling
you it would be an intoxicant to a lot
of undecided voters Otis think I don't
ask you about the future of the
Republican Party and then I want to get
back into your history and how you got
into all this stuff for folks who don't
know your story
but first what helps you fall asleep
noise machines essential oils some silly
device attached to your mouth what if
the reason that you're actually not
sleeping is that your mattress sucks
because it wasn't designed for you you
just got a generic mattress but you're
not a generic human hulex sleep has a
quiz it takes two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or a
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
a firm bed with helix there's no more
confusion and no more compromising helix
sleep is rated the number one mattress
by GQ and Wired magazine and CNN and
called it the most comfortable mattress
they've ever slept on just go to helix
sleep calm / men take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life for couples
helix can even split the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
they have a 10 year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
is offering up to 125 dollars off all
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 125 bucks off at helix sleep comm
slash been the Tilak's lucam / been for
up to 125 dollars off your mattress
order helix sleep comm / been their
incredibly comfortable I've got one my
wife and I took that two minutes late
because the mattress just arrived in the
mail and inflated in front of us we
popped it on the bed and we were good to
go
it's so good my sister has one we got it
for her for her wedding as well go check
them out right now at helix sleep comm /
Ben that's helix sleep comm / Ben you
can save up to 125 bucks off your
mattress order helix sleep comm / Ben
already so I want to ask you about the
future of the Republican parties we're
talking about the Democrats who are off
the track there they seem to be
disconnected from at least a huge
percentage of the American public where
do you think the future of the
Republican Party lies because I do think
that there is a certain mythos that's
been built up about president Trump as
sort of great political figure when in
fact statistically he performs basically
in line with how george w bush performed
in a lot of the swing states how MIT
Romney performed actually in a lot of
the swing states what do you think the
future of the Republican Party is you
are always saying that you were a
socially liberal but fiscally
conservative do you think that we're
moving in a more libertarian direction
or a more populist direction where do
you think the future the conservative
movement alized real quickly just let me
put a button on to them side of this I
think Hillary is going to be the
unlikeliest cavalry riding over the hill
I honestly think he's coming back I'm
looking at this her relative silence not
all the time but and I think somebody
has told her listen unless they see you
the better they play it you play you
should stay out of the way we've got a
circular shooting range here you get 18
guys 14 of them shouldn't have driver's
licenses for could not pass the a CT
test half these people you should shut
up come in at the end and say and when
they say we you said you weren't gonna
run say they demanded it I I don't want
to I'm doing this for the good country
that's where I think the Democrats are
going I wouldn't really rise especially
with Biden falling apart me what do you
make of all the accusations about Biden
in his candidacy which seems to be on
the ropes this early Biden should get
back to his actual job which is being
the third guy in a car on a sonic
commercial you know for years I've been
hearing about what genius Joe Biden
and Sammy's one of those big
glad-handing doofuses who went into the
bubble when he's 29 he's 75 and every
time I seen he's there I don't want Iran
do this reluctantly but I have to help
and Joe if you're out there and you
watch Ben and you know probably you do I
want to tell you stop helping me I I let
you free go out and help yourself
it 875 because at this point it's a you
know to me he's more unhinged there's
shaky er than a rescue dog and Phil
Spector's house and live when they
always act like he's a bunker I think I
guess I'm missing that because to me
he's the sort of guy who you know it
looks like he thinks bottled water
tastes better after you shake it Biden
is gonna go in he's gonna get in for the
reason that they created they birthed
this monster this whole thing about now
do I find it weird to Joe Biden's
leaning in on strangers and smelling
their hair I guess it's fetishistic or
so I don't know I don't know what that
is do I think that should be a reason he
doesn't run for president no but do I
think that might end up being a reason
yeah I mean that's that's where it's at
right now but they started this stuff
you know if anybody out so that's one
thing we should be able to agree to in
his culture if you said which way is
political correctness coming from the
left or the right I think anybody would
have to concede between college
professors and Hollywood's social media
and boy yen's that mostly the left
demands that you walk in a very tight
lockstep I've been you know on both
sides of this issue over the years and I
can tell you the people on the right
side Oh up to their ass kicking a lot
easier than the left I think Christians
are almost used to it you know they
don't are they calling for anybody's
heads or they you know what I mean it's
they regularly get poked fun at and they
kind of move on with it
the left's the one who have gotten so PC
now that Biden probably will be done in
by the same thing that he now has to
cater to it's weird to watch him watch
this will lend a thing in the same week
he has to go back and apologize for his
performance at the Anita Hill thing he
also has to you know say that I didn't
really mean that meaning when I leaned
in but now he has to qualify that and
say I see that the space is different
now try to modulate
and I think wow it is a hard job over
there keeping up on the daily PC casting
list and that's exactly right especially
because the same week that Joe Biden is
doing all of this stuff the entire
Democratic Party descended and paid
homage to Al Sharpton Yeah right who's
like one of the worst people in human
history and they're all going to the
National Action Network and they're
pretending like he's some sort of great
political kingmaker you know three
decades after he pulled the justice
Millette with Tawana Brawley I you know
I met him once and I couldn't call him
Reverend a you know I interviewed him
once I said listen now I can't do the
reverend thing you know yeah I must
admit it was pretty it was pretty easy
about it I just said too much you know
there's too much stuff that's going you
know you agreed about that haberdasher
up in Harlem who was ended up getting
killed I mean this is rough stuff when
you make these accusations that are
false so I don't respect I don't respect
the house Sharpton at all and by the way
that weight loss I think he just got to
a point where he had so violated the
sacrosanct promise that not overusing
the minibar on speaking engagements so
they actually had to cut it out of his
writer that's when he got thin yeah I
think that man was entirely filled with
a Grey Goose and Toblerone it just
turned into a Macy's below everybody
season now what are you doing you got ID
cards nine up on the minibar so much
they had to take it out of my right but
now all of a sudden to watch them kiss
his ring is just unbelievable to me
and that's what I mean about that 10% in
the middle and forty forty five forty
five we're gonna go against him or for
him that ten in the middle I think see
stuff like that and says oh really
is he the gatekeeper now on all this
he's not even a good guy now you had
asked me before about where do I think
the Republicans are going I don't know I
haven't paid attention to the
Republicans it's not Republican it's
Trump and in an odd way he has turned
out to be very concerned I mean he's led
I would say on most big issues you're
more conservative than me I'm I'm pretty
conservative but you know he's done
pretty well as far as checking
conservative boxes hasn't he
well certainly with regard to tax cuts
with cutting regulation with appointing
conservative judges moving
he's done a lot of great stuff I mean
though the one area where I think the
Republican Party continues to be a giant
fail is of course on spending in
entitlements and they will be a fail for
as long as many things failed on that
this is the reason stuff that I think
you can talk about where they should
talk about it with him yeah we're
spending our ass off I don't think we're
spending at the same speed that we did
under Obama but certainly it's not
enough of a thing where you go he's not
back on that I think that I can't judge
Republicans because I don't feel
Republicans been in there I feel an
unlikely conservative guy I view Trump
as the guy we got to the place where
this whole thing if they had had another
eight years to sort of cement solidify
smooth over appease tamp down problems
with the you know the the Hillary's the
the dossier and all that if if they had
another eight years to do that I don't
think this country was coming back and
when people say well what do you mean
coming back to you that sounds
apocalyptic I just mean it would have
turned into some huge source
Scandinavian country and it would have
you know people over here it would have
been scammed and a fear because
everybody would have been beating the
system and you wouldn't a shot for the
moon anymore all that stuff I think is
what would have changed if Hillary got
in I think it would have became a
single-payer health care system I think
all these things kind are not the
country I grew up excited about where
you went for it so that's all I'm saying
what happened do I think it would turn
into a round up everybody you know I
don't want to be apocalyptic about Trump
actually turned around and said now what
about self-determine ISM what about what
about we go for it in as individuals and
then that makes the yield curve go up so
I admire him for that that's what I like
about the country I like a can-do
attitude and I was always puzzled the
most enamoured I ever was of Michelle
Obama's I saw her speaking one night and
on TV and she was talking about how her
father who she adored beyond all others
would come home in between shifts and
take an hour at home and that bounce her
on the her lap as a young girl and then
he'd go back out leave you know it's
it's almost like caveman
if you leave the cave to procure meat
for the young ones and imagine the you
have your dad he's smiling at you he's
come from a bust his ass job he's going
to another imagine a young girl sitting
there and wow there's a man for you and
then later in life I thought why do you
want to turn this stuff over to Chuck
Schumer you know what I mean why do you
want your old man's the government to be
in charge of what was the most important
moment in your life I never I've never
understood that part of it when people
say to you why are you conservative
stuff like that I always love the
American dream I always loved it going
for it no guarantees I always work well
when my cat's-paws heels are backed over
the abyss man you know I mean I hustle
that and I think if it's all if it's all
soft landing it's like I defy people to
tell me they didn't use to dig the
Wallendas more when there was no net you
put the net in you're still there but
it's finally falling and that's I don't
know that's my big prata station with a
entitlement so weird this view come from
when did you actually become four
realize that you were politically
conservative wait listen I ain't grown
Pittsburgh and Pittsburgh's a no BS town
so you work hard for your money so
that's in my hard drive I remember as I
got older it was important and this was
pretty late in time
comparatively it wasn't a childhood
thing Admiral Stockdale was a big thing
for me because I remember thinking
remember Stockdale was pickle in
Winnsboro is that a rose 92 okay so
we're now going on in 17 years and I
remember Jesus I can't believe life's
molding guy like that
but he picks stock down Stockdale goes
on TV and he's this is a man who was in
the Hanoi Hilton for God's sakes tapping
out codes of prayers two young men who
you know they'd say Jimmy and so eight
wants to die you know and he would pray
with them through the night good imagine
a more I don't know I always hear that
it makes me cry thinking about the kid
who wants to just die you know just stop
trying to live and die and this man
getting on and
praying with him in codes recites it
just boggles my mind at the nobility of
that he goes on TV and says I don't even
know what I'm doing here
they naturally excised that clip and
make him look like some doddering fool
and I'm thinking forgot to fix the
vice-president's we've had over the
years coin was a vice president and you
know I don't make fun of quail except I
don't think he's a man he's a historical
figure to me so certainly Stockdale
could do this job that was a big moment
for me when the left started rid of
killing him I remember thinking this
room's getting too hip for me if guys
like that are you know gonna be
disparaged at the expense of other guys
who are quite frankly just hacks who
went into a system ages ago and no huh
you know to me much of politics is the
ability the best people added or the
ability to look at the crowd they're
speaking to and point an individual watt
and actually have that individual think
they must have met at some point it's
always that like I always see them go
and I think there's more to it than that
that's about there's a guy who doesn't
know how to do that but answers the call
to save a young man's life in the most
horrid situation on earth so that was a
big shift for me that you know some of
the stuff was in my hard drive I just
believe I'd like to keep 50 cents on a
dollar I think I live in the best
country in the world I think I'd like to
keep one for everyone I give away and
then when I croak I'd like that the half
that I kept to go to my kids you know
people always say well why do you want
your kid you want to spoil them and I
want to say hey why do I want to spoil
your kids I don't know your kids
yeah my kids give me joy I suppose about
yeah I'd like to keep a little that's my
Vig for making it and having kids how's
about that
so that never made that part of it
didn't make sense I mean after 9/11
let's say anybody who was able to like
wrap 9/11 up and move on get it be
whatever hair people's it's time to get
it behind us like what are you kidding
me it's it's primal it's it's in the
hard drive now as much as I'd like
people to work hard for the money I
remember thinking oh we got to get
serious now I don't know what serious is
I'm not a wizard walkabout foreign
policy but 18 guy
were able to do that and that's a
dangerous world so that changed me a
little too so how do people in Hollywood
react when they realized what your
politics were so can take me through
sort of what your resume was how what
was your career progression here because
a lot of people know you at like certain
times so people know you from SNL or
they know you from your show on CNBC or
they know you from your radio show but
what was the the sort of timeline in
career promote listen when I was on SNL
and I was talking about earlier about a
business decision I had some political
leanings but man when you get hired to
do the news on SNL you're there to make
fun of power and that was Reagan at the
time I didn't even know that much about
Reagan honest to god I mean I these
people always act like that they were
you're I remember talking to you and
you're in the amniotic sac and you're
smart but I I didn't say that much
attention honest to god and I had no
trouble lighting up Reagan he was an
older cat power
I was the Weekend Update anchor you know
you're supposed to be scaramouche it's
the you gotta come out and flourish the
Cape a little so III made fun of him but
I can't even say I knew everything he
stood for but if I if I go back I do
believe we had some basic overlaps and
I've seen old specials of myself where I
do have a pragmatic side that comes
through even when I'm trying to be a
hipster as a young man I would say 9/11
was a big thing I would say Stockdale is
a big thing and I think just common
sense is a big thing I wasn't certain
enough of my guesswork to be liberal
anymore that was such a degree of
certitude about the same sort of you
know or flip a coin that most of us do
as I got older it just didn't make sense
to me anymore some of that stuff and as
I get older yet it still doesn't make
sense to me any listen they always say
oh he Trump's insane and I guess Obama's
held up as the avatar of you know wisdom
in that and I always think who who loads
1.8 billion onto a pallet since erect I
mean I'm kind of people say that's so
naive oh yeah I can hear John Kerry
asleep and I yeah will you overthink it
I just know they live to kill the Jews I
dig the Jews I'm not even Jewish but I
dig the Jews just because they live in
the craziest called the sack in the
world and anytime you pre-packaged 1.8
just the fact that they would asked for
it
- I'd say why don't I just give you a
check and fill the memo section I killed
Jews you know what I mean it's not
anytime you send that unmarked cash door
and some of its gonna end up bombing a
Sbarro pizza parlor that stuff doesn't
make sense to me and I can't fake like
it does I have to stop down on each
issue and more socially some of the
liberal stuff makes sense to me but on
basic common-sense things so that would
be my progression I I think when I was
on HBO I was on there for ten seasons I
think 215 shows and as I look at it I
was always a pragmatist but maybe in the
second half of it I was just more openly
skeptical about some of the BS you know
I can remember having Tim Robbins on one
night and that's just probably it's
hurting okay he said I said where you
been Jimmy what are you doing he said
I've been on the road for with Bill
Clinton for two weeks campaigning I said
that's twice in your life you had that
crawl through a pipe filled with a skew
you've done a bunch of these jobs which
one of them did you like the best that
kind of mix of comedy and politics but
first no one really has time to go to
the post office you're busy who's got
time for all that traffic parking
lugging all your mail and packages it's
a real hassle I know last time I went to
the post office
I got a traffic ticket that's why you
need stamps calm one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps calm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service direct
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps calm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps calm you get
five cents off every first-class stamp
and up to 40% off Priority Mail as a
hell of a deal not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps calm is a
no-brainer saves you time it saves you
money
it's no wonder over 700,000 businesses
ready use stamps calm right now my
listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
comm click on the mic at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that stamps.com
enter Shapiro so obviously you've had a
pretty varied career her which which one
of these did you like the most but you
did enjoy well let me go through them I
was a stand-up comedian I dug it but I
was broke at the beginning you're broke
I can remember being out on the road
it's a brutal scene you go into the
comedy condo and there's Andromeda
Strain on the shower curtain you know
like you know nothing's gonna clean but
you're out there at least then I was
able to tell my sub yeah bro then nobody
throws your bone so the they have to
throw you the bone so shut off lay low
keep your nose to the grindstone to get
through this as quickly as possible but
you'd see club owners taking kids
audition tapes and taping the Winter
Olympics over them you know it's just
like gladiator camp you know and I
thought well I'm gonna go down hard so
you know I got all Spartacus about it I
look back on and I'm such a wuss but at
the time I thought well just gonna be
tough so I got tough and then I got I
was seen for Saturday Night Live I'd
have to say that's you know to answer
the question but we can go through the
other ones if you want but that's that's
the biggest change I mean you know you
come in from Baltimore I remember I was
in Baltimore getting the stomach
poisoning it as though I won't say the
name of the company because I've eaten
their sins but in a place that I met all
of a sudden two days later you're healed
up and you're in New York you're on
Letterman and I remember I had
auditioned for Saturday Night Live and
didn't get it they showed the cast in
USA Today and I thought I remember I was
so tough at that point I even saw that
picture and just said all right now your
time brother you know it wasn't like I I
just thought it's brutal don't waste a
second you know being a wuss about this
get your Rhino skin together it's like
for John I do Letterman they say Lorne
Michaels wants to see up on 17 no I know
something's up because he's not gonna
call me up Lauren hates awkwardness he's
having me up to talk about something I
don't know what he's gonna proffer maybe
an appearance I go up and I sit outside
his office for an hour and then they say
Laurens ready and I go in and he's
sitting at the end it's a beautiful
scene it's burned into my skull
like a great Engram or something
Scientology they always have the bum on
emigrants this is a good one I can't get
this out of my mind I looked at he's got
half glasses on one of those beautiful
green table lamps over his shoulder is
the Empire State Building in some tree
killer status and he looks at me goes
Dennis how would you like to be the
Weekend Update anchor and I said well
I'd like that a lot he's our see a 10
and it was that's and I walked out and
your life's never the same after that I
find out the Lovitz were supposed to do
weekend anchor but he was in so many
things that they needed the time this is
the vagaries of life they needed the
time between the band who would play and
the weekend update' to dress him out in
prosthetics for some of the characters
he did
thus I get the gig and so if I had to
say what my biggest change was it was
that and also the most enjoyable here in
the bunker its life in a bunker you know
how that accelerates the emotion of
relationships you're talking about
really brutal place where it's fun to
but if you screw up three weeks in a row
you're dead I mean you're gone to the
point where you you know then nobody
sniffs you it's like an injured player
in the NFL nobody wants to be around it
they know there's a taint on yes I dug
that action when I was a kid I don't
know if ever the nurse for it now but at
the time it felt like savoir faire then
after that I went I was looking for an
exit point because I didn't want to be a
guy who overstayed his welcome there
I remember in college there was always
the guy who came back after he'd
graduated the next year and hung out
near the keg trying to tap it and get
laid and I always thought what a weird
scene that is so I didn't want to
overstay my welcome sir a 6-year point I
looked for a point to jettison the fuel
module and get out for money and I got a
nice gig in a syndicated show but it got
whacked after six or eight months I went
home that was one time I remember being
hangdog but michael Fuchs who headed up
HBO called me the next morning and I had
done a couple specials for him and we
got on and he said listen you know lick
your wounds heal up and we'll do
something here and he gave me three
shows on the air at HBO the second one
won an Emmy and then I got 215 at that
point I began to disengage from actively
judging how good my life was going
through job or not job
I remember thinking you know I had this
theory about
lump in your armpit theory used to
keep me through well I think you could
get fired from a job and be like is this
consulate as you want and be in the
shower the next morning think god I
can't believe they whacked me and all of
a sudden you find a lump in your armpit
as you're lying or not and you know your
wife goes what were you saying about
losing the job honey and you get a screw
that I've got a lump in my armpit what's
what does that matter
so I started to get that insight I was
probably in my 30s at this point that
the jobs didn't matter that much that
you had to have some fun and the journey
it sounds a little new agey but it was
true so I did that for a long time that
ended
I got Monday Night Football guts I got
that horse shot out from under me and
sue sue two years but I I had fun but I
knew I wasn't long for that one because
I was trying to shoehorn what I do which
is weird Arcania I remember they'd get
bail like I remember a cable can you say
that and you said everyone yeah okay
I'll tell you a great story we're doing
a game one night and this receiver hurts
his ankle and they're wrapping it and
they spend it on the air I try to make
now laughs and the weird Arcania is what
makes him laugh because that was a
genius but if you throw him off his feet
he can't gather it and he's like a tipsy
air traffic controller it gets a little
weird so I spend all my time trying to
get him to laugh so they show wrapping
the ankle and I go you know how I
haven't seen that much fabric used since
the environment artist Christo wrapped
the Pont Neuf bridge in Paris and I
remember al it's just these button which
cuts his voice out to the home viewer it
looks like all Myers are produced is
done in a truck and he fancies himself
an art aficionado I actually or him say
no al Christa environmental artist good
call good call delighting in that but
yeah I'm not long you can't you know
they're watching football I would have
whacked me too there's like when I heard
Madden left Fox
I called Fouts that morning he was our
third guy in a blue they called dam
Phong's i said listen work it's ji
gordon liddy time just tell them what
corner you're gonna be on so innocent
still getting hit in the crossfire
gone later today they just realize I
don't care but that Madden has not left
Fox to sit up in the Dakotas with the
old lady and drink frappuccinos all day
he's coming over here
sure enough they whack us later today I
would have whacked me - it's the way of
the world
if you enlisted if I'm ever in LA on any
given night and I want to do stand-up
and I go into the improv and John
Madden's on stage they better haul his
fat ass off - that's the way the world
works so after football what did i do
then I went to CNBC and I didn't even
want to do that but there's a number
they hit I'll make the drive that's way
I mean you can be all ethereal about
showbiz but at some point they hit the
number you know I listen I'm a
breadwinner go win some bread and then
from there I got uh I got the perfect
gig which was I was on for six minutes a
week with a rally right and I didn't
even have to do the heavy lifting
because he didn't he didn't want me to
he wanted to say hey Miller there's a
robot in Korea and you know he's so
footage or spring break so he could show
the bikini 4tj times in a row you know
what about these kids so I was sort of
like the hinge joint that would let me
like take the weird stories I did that
for five years I made a good buck and
the best thing was we'd go on the road
where some 10,000 seats for yeah you
know Riley's like a Commerce machine and
you're some 10,000 seats so I just rode
that I didn't do anything else for six
years but then a rally quickly and in
the interim I've just been sort of
looking for something else but nothing's
shown itself at this point and like I
said I had a great talk with dado Carvey
we're at Target I said I don't know you
think it's politics car and he's there
do you think it has anything to do with
the fact that we're midway through our
60s you know he's brutal to curve about
the nature of showbiz so at this point
I'm I don't know I like doing this a bit
but it's not like I wake up every
morning thinking where's the side hustle
I'm sated so what are your parents like
I mean growing up where did the comedy
come from well I remember being in high
school and I was completely ostracized
because it was so shy but I remember I
sat in a study hall next to the star
tight end
on the on the football team and under my
breath I would make him laugh
and I was just Pavlov's dog at that
point you're talking about a kid who was
I might as well been any Slovak walking
down to the the electric chair all alone
all of a sudden the tight-end says you
want to walk between classes you know
and I'm thinking wow I get it now I make
them laugh and I'm included so that's
when I started you know it's funny so I
think funnies a I don't think funny is
some mystical sword from the stone
moment I think you have to have a
perspective that's a little quirky and I
think the best guys have a quirky
perspective but it's like Seinfeld
always said you sit near the faucet
these and most people watch the drip go
down the drain you cuff your hands and
catch the drip put it under the
jeweler's loupe
and feed it back to them do you manage
to make a living it's uh it's it's less
Camelot and more you know just pay
attention and after the initial thing
you shouldn't let yourself be afraid
after in a month you should at the
beginning its petrified but then I
remember at the end of the month
thinking well the option is to hand this
to strangers and watch them score with
it and I don't have that sort of if some
guys have that where they can sit behind
the scenes I I didn't I thought force
yourself through this vomitus feeling
and tell your own jokes brother this is
gonna back up on you so how much of your
of your worth you actually craft how
what's your kind of workflow when you're
what I do especially you have the whole
thing and then it's an interesting thing
I don't have the memory I used to so
what I do is put a prompter in the back
of the room and I have a button on stage
right near my right foot and I leave the
prompter off because everybody wants to
do it but just knowing that it's there
bullet points if I get to a point where
I'm just for a second I it's slipped my
mind or yeah and like I said I'm yeah I
don't have the memory I didn't when I
was a kid I used to remember it like
that I just go like that and the kid
turns the prompter on on the bullet
point I'm at and then I hit it turn it
off and then you're good for another 20
minutes but on especially right
everything the way I develop jokes is
I'll go up with the I used to always try
to when I was stuck on SNL I had this
big poster on my wall
where you know Friday come Friday nobody
wants to hear your sad tale about how
you don't have Weekend Update together
and like I said you do if I didn't do
that good for three weeks well for three
weeks in a row a Whitney Brown would be
co-hosting so I'd get motivated at a
certain point I'd think you better write
jokes now you better shut up on the
whining and I'd look up at the poster
and it said indignation what am i arcane
reference it was like a basic I am back
bent a Matar four jugs cuz I would get
to the point where I'd say you know I
went to the doctor he said I was a
little stiff one of my Rosie the robot
mate you know it would signal it or
would trip me off and and then I'd think
how easy it was you have to at some
point have a little you have to be
debonair about it you know you have to
be mystify it and then you have to feel
proud of it so at the beginning I
remember I went on Letterman the first
time in Biff the guy who lets you
backstage after if you don't get called
over says hey what's your last two lines
so I know when to pull the curtain and
that was a big thing I remember saying
that demystified it for me so eventually
you get through that part and then
Weekend Update I remember thing and
taking it to the next level thinking I
am taking it level was a value judgment
I everybody did the best I could but I
remember thinking you better do some
panache now brother cuz they want
somebody out there it doesn't look like
he's looking at his feet shuffling and
acting apologetic they want a matador so
start getting in closer to the horns
that's when I started putting savoir
faire in and all the goofy affectations
and I just remembered that the the
during the week I had a perfect thing I
was in New York City if I had a joke I
wasn't sure about you go out to a club
and you go up and tell it and it doesn't
have to kill but you have to get
something that lets you know it has a
pulse you know and so it was a perfect
lab I was just smart enough to think
don't drink don't get loaded you know
I've never done blow or anything you
know like it was a crazy time I just
remember thinking I talked to Leto about
he said stay on the road I know the road
looks crowded now but I'm telling you
everybody starts going off the road for
pleasures or neuroses he's and it was
true I just like wrote my jokes and shut
up and didn't get loaded
you know it opened up so you're famous
for being so arcane that they threw you
off Monday Night Football because of it
so where did all these nuttin other
reasons I don't want to make it strictly
that but like I said John Madden's the
best color and I people think I'm all
wounded and ding he should do that job
the moment he wanted it I like it said
but yes also the Arcania doesn't only
serve but then it does it listen people
act like you're some cat who gets the
dim sum around and say I think I'll be
this funny from this direction
it's my one monkey trick I got a
somewhat deep drawer in a nice retrieval
system that's all I got bad I mean it's
not like I'm sitting I'm not Moliere I'm
not an old coward
everybody's got their strengths I did
learn a lesson from a great comic named
Richard Belzer early on bells ended up
being an actor on Law & Order right yeah
yeah then when he was young in the 70s
he ruled New York City a catcher izing
star he was like Anton LaVey the Dark
Prince man and he was so non caring
about whether they dug him or not there
was a big lesson for me because I was I
would go up there I had this talk with
Carlin once when he was young on The Ed
Sullivan Show he said I look back I'm
coming on I'm practically a band singer
you know and then he just said screw it
I'm gonna push all my chips in on charge
Carly came out long sweater hair and a
beard like looking like the Prophet he
just he rolled the dice and said if I'm
gonna take this up the next level when I
watch it Belzer I remember thinking I'm
such an ass kiss out there I'm so needy
to be liked I've got to drop that and I
find out in a very important lesson at
least in a confined space a room people
don't want you to be asked kisi they
find it unctuous they want you in this
chair this is the Objectivist in me I'm
reading Atlas Shrugged as we speak again
and part of it so if part of its weird
to me the most part of it the self
determinism part I find really
exhilarating
I remember thinking they don't want you
to be up there being sucky like dag
knees brother Jim in the mauville they
want you to be like hey step up and do
your thing and do it confidently and
they're freed up to dig you because they
don't have to worry about your
self-esteem you know I remember it to be
crowds would look up and nervous
laughter is them thinking you seem like
a reasonable a nice guy and they don't
want you to fail
they've diverted their shields like that
Star Trek away from just flat-out
laughing into protecting you in some way
if you go up and start giving off that
sort of Garbo thing that you don't care
of anybody ever sees you again it's it's
it's an intoxicant to them that's
showbiz
some more rice politics too right I mean
President Trump is that I mean there's
no question that it were never seen
anybody like that I'm telling you here's
the thing I think about Trump say what
you will about him I think his outer
voice is an entirely accurate depiction
of his inner voice oh yeah there's no
crazy as that is on sick days I don't
think Hillary Clinton's in her voice an
otter voice have ever even had a cup of
coffee together I think that's why he's
the President of the United States right
now yeah I think there's very little
question about that so who are you some
of your favorite comedians you had to
rank comedians historically like
historically for your favorites and then
who are some people working now you like
well listen when I was a kid Jonathan
winters made me how because he was easy
to understand you could air drop him
anywhere in the world and the faces and
the funny voices and his ability to
improv was liberating so I saw that when
I was young that stuck in my head then
the next thing I saw like that was Robin
in his first HBO special where he he was
so untethered and Robin became a movie
star now but when his young stand up
just to watch somebody that carefree I
knew I could never do that but I
remember thinking god that must feel
like a loofah scrub on your brain to go
up and be you're always so garden in
front of strangers to go up and be that
unguarded and must you must feel
bulletproof when you walk out so that
was cool I went to see a comedian named
Kelly Monteith who was nice enough to
have me backstage and I don't even know
if Kelly's still with us but I always
kissed the ring because I was a young
kid thinking I can't do Robin but I
think I can do what Kelly's doing and I
don't mean proficiency wise I just mean
that sort of delivery at a mic and
imagine what a sweet man he is to have
me back a kid unknown who does not even
a comedian to say I'm contemplating it
for 10 minutes backstage and giving me
some guidance very important thing next
guy I saw was Jay he
mystified it for me he was a stone
killer on stage I know people see J on
The Tonight Show
JJ's smart enough to serve a task and
the task was to win that for 17 years
and he did that was his prime directive
on there he did a great model I'm
telling you Jay Leno off stage is wicked
I just talked to him last night he just
stoned killer so that was important the
next guy Seinfeld I remember seeing
Seinfeld in New York and thinking well I
don't think I should watch him anymore
because that's - that's insightful you
know I mean Jay it was about socks and a
dryer but it was such a clever take I
remember he did joke one night and all
of us maybe click show it was so deftly
where he said I watch a parakeet fly
into a mirror and I always think well
sure they're there low brainpower but
that being said wouldn't he want to
avoid the oncoming parakeet have to
leave the room and say I'm mad I'm
writing jokes well I gotta go somewhere
because that's way down here and so he
was important and then today I would say
the funniest man in the world is Brian
Regan it was a brilliant comedy comedian
who the beauty of it is you have kids
yeah I know if you still good grant the
kids grandparents but you could take all
of them to this thing from 10 and I
don't say this about a lot of guys to 80
and they all walk out like with
temporomandibular joint syndrome they've
been laughing so hard
he's a flat-out genius Jerry still you
know Jerry's Mount Rushmore he's the man
and there's a cat named Sebastian
Maniscalco who does sort of a it's about
his upbringing that's a little more that
guy you know crown the stage and he I
don't my son and I go to see him and
literally we were in trouble I think the
hardest I've ever left I have a good
memory I could say always worked for me
because he but I loved him and he made
me laugh the single hardest time I've
ever seen with Sam kind of sign I don't
know if you're familiar with Sam but it
was just so wrong like sometimes he'd be
so wrong that you'd sit there and this
is what we talked about with political
correctness now we've we've like augered
out a huge bit of what makes you laugh
sometimes wrong
or unfair or mean is what makes you
laugh the hardest
I remember Sam convulsing me one night
there was a group of people in from
Decatur Illinois or something or in the
Comedy Store it's like 2:00 in the
morning there the light he's the last
guy Sam comes out he hasn't broken big
yet he's getting big though but he comes
out he's like some pissed-off Gollum
he's got the beret on and the coat and
they don't quite know what to make of
him where he in from and he starts
talking to them and they think he's nice
no idea they're dealing with the antic
what are you doing the guy describes and
sam says yeah sounds good hey listen
around 3 o'clock after hearing that
story around 3 o'clock tomorrow
afternoon I'm gonna be doing some yard
work and if there's anybody else in the
crowd who wants to drive by and it was
like the beginning of the mask and some
to where the eyes are coming up and
that's now looking back at that that's
the hardest I've ever left I've
everything this is I was with a comedian
named Jeff Caesarea now I look back on
that I don't have any choice in that I
look back on it and is it like great
moments in comedy no it's not exactly
deft but it was just so wrong and the
the equilibrium was so thrown off maybe
it was nervousness but it just made me
laugh my ass off and I often think now
all that's dead Sam would be out of the
business today so would Rickles I mean
yeah I think Rickles might get through
cuz he was a softy he had a good heart
but Sam was just playing Sam had a good
heart but he's more malevolent I don't
think either those guys could work down
that's a weird place to be in that
starts gonna ask you next is about the
modern standards you know it seems to me
that we've actually returned to a sort
of Puritanism about comedy where if the
only jokes that you're allowed to make
are basically sex jokes all the other
jokes are out the window because they
rely on stereotypes or they rely on
observations about reality that could be
offensive to somebody sex is inherently
funny so you can make a sex joke an get
away with it or you can just shock
somebody by cursing or saying something
incredibly lewd or vulgar but it seems
like that's
it's either that or or you know probing
social commentary meaning just left a
social commentary you can watch on
Maddow
so is there a future for comedy in this
in this world you know there always is
but I can't foresee it you know what I
mean something's going to happen in this
country that's gonna uncap this pressure
hey what was the guy's name ray Donovan
where do I go to get my reputation back
or I think there was a guy named Walsh
who one time said have you no shame you
know it Hollywood's running the tightest
Torquemada type thing now and it's a
it's not McCarthyism it's like Jenny
McCarthyism yeah you can be you can be
kicked out in a second for saying
something wrong supposedly by the cool
kids that that makes me I never sought I
never thought I'd see that coming and
now I can't say how I see it going but I
do think there'll be some moment where
something is uh overplayed somebody has
a rank it might almost happen with
Monica Lewinsky but she saved that dress
I mean when you look back on that people
always say that's such an odd thing I
thank God they would have driven that
young girl I think into a nervous break
something's gonna happen it's gonna make
us all step back and go oh that's uh
that's heavy you know and that's weird
and we've got to start but I can't
foresee what that is but it's gonna be
it's not gonna be a minor thing some
something's gonna come out of this
perpetually uptight attitude that's
gonna make everybody shake their head
and think oh we've gone too far well one
of the things I wonder is whether
there's been too much of a merger of
politics and comedy so you're mentioning
Leno before the fact that Leno really
what he really did try to play it
straight when he was on The Tonight Show
avoiding ticking off one side at the
expense of the other he would actually
tell jokes about about both sides and
now it seems like it's you're not
allowed to make jokes about one side of
the aisle and you'll hear comedians say
things openly like well there wasn't
anything funny about Barack Obama I just
think to myself how is there nothing
funny about Barack Obama there's plenty
funny about Barack Obama it's what makes
you question what comedy is doesn't hurt
in another way it makes me question I
don't know I don't sound like I'm gonna
be Kierkegaard or something here but the
the subjectification of the empirical is
a great puzzlement to me
and it's why I think somewhere down the
road you literally could have two plus
two equal in the it equals when you
start putting in tenth feelings emotion
ahead of well what's it equal what what
if two twos are for that that's what's
happened now is I often wonder well how
am I looking at Nancy Pelosi and seeing
sort of a disingenuous person who's been
in that system for so long her one
genius is knowing how to play that that
micro world the cheese in of sharp
elbows and but when I watch her I don't
think she's a great intellect and then I
have other people you hear people
talking about her she's our last hope
she's a great intellect and I look at
that I think well is it just egotistical
for me to do you ever have this moment
where you think well what is separating
these two it's my opinion and I start to
wonder is there an actual thing out
there or is there is there not is it
just how you see it I want to ask you
for a second about what seems to me a
transformational point in comedy was was
the rise of Comedy Central and
particularly Stewart's show the the that
I think that Stewart's show had had
almost a cataclysmic impact on the
merger of politics and comedy and
because Stewart was so incredibly
talented he was able to get away with
the merger of the two but it's sort of
killed comedy to merge it with politics
in the way that in the way that Stewart
did where he would read a headline and
then he make a funny face at the
audience and then the audience would
laugh simply at the headline and it
wasn't an actual joke about the headline
it was just we laugh at the headline
itself and so it became that politicians
were now comedians cuz I can read a
headline too and comics became
politicians there was an actual merger
of the two and you can't separate it off
and that means there's no actual leeway
for comedians anymore it used to be that
if you're a comic you could say
something deeply offensive and terrible
and completely get away with it because
you just say right I'm a comic that's
what I do I'm here to affect why they
came to you right exactly and now it's
well know you're not allowed to say that
just you and that defense is that as the
comic doesn't doesn't obtain anymore
because the thing that that bothered me
about Stewart's routine was that it was
clown nose on clown nose off sometimes
it was that he was the clown and
sometimes he was not the clowns when he
was appearing with Tucker Carlson on
crossfire and ripping into the horrible
things the crossfire was doing to the
world he was now
being a comedian and then you'd go back
on Comedy Central you put the clown nose
back on and I think people stopped being
able to tell the difference between the
people who were the comedians and the
people who are the politicians and
you're seeing that with with Kimmel
right now who's being seen as a moral
voice as opposed to a guy who was
supposed to make you laugh on late-night
I think the job descriptions changed
I think he's hittin the job description
now and at some point this does come
down to individuals who have ceased
great jobs I mean really
where's Jimmy Kimmel gonna go where's
Stephen Colbert Stephen Colbert was I
believe in third place and probably in
trouble Trump got like that he's in
first place that he's left at some point
you it is a Skinner box about your
Pavlov's dog what are you do go and get
the electric shock you want the corn
kernel those might be their beliefs but
I'm also saying even if they weren't
their beliefs really they gonna come out
there and start no you wouldn't have
that gig so I can't cut through that
part of it how much is that I do know
this the people who I think have gone in
the bubble for so long mostly in
Hollywood I think there's always a
haunting thing you hear great people
talking about people who've built great
fortunes talking about I was almost a
little haunted I didn't get a college
degree or and I always think why what
does that matter and it seemed like a
jerk-off thing to me they always say
that I look at the eye I look at people
in Hollywood I think they're a little
haunted by their good fortune although
some of our great artists but some of
them have a mug that works some of them
are at the right place at the right time
I think they're always a little haunted
so they're trying to legitimize
themselves now by being you know
professorial and I've got some wisdom
here and you're saying you're the fifth
lead on full house Pepperidge Farm
Alyssa Milano's there's no filling but
the the fact is that the guys like Trump
Trump lived the whole life I feel I
don't think he feels any need that you
know when people say how can he say
those things I don't think he's look
thinking to look wise I think he's kind
of built his what he thinks Donald Trump
is and now he's just gonna upset the
entire apple cart all I know is this I
don't watch the Oscars anymore I had a
chance to last year but they had
somebody also are for me too
the kayak solo across the Pacific with a
rabid meerkat my lap so I often put that
on there to look lies now and you go to
Trump press conferences for laughs now
just so when people say well how did we
get I can't even tell you how we got
there much less how we get back but I
would say if I had one hot lead on how
we got there is people started people in
tertiary industry started taking
themselves serious about knowing how the
world works
honest-to-god when I go out and do my
thing III I say that now these all stop
at the end of my fingertips I'm barely
getting through
I've been puzzled confused mistaken you
know my whole life that but you there's
a degree of surety now that comes along
with the the self-righteous nature of
being right and you just look at the you
know for instance have real quick and
pontificating but I always looked back
to 1965 it's a big thing for me the
institution of the Great Society which
was ostensibly supposed to help the
disenfranchised great intent
I guess LBJ's know trying to level his
climb out from the NAM you know what I
mean so he's thinking I hear on the home
front I'll try to help the
disenfranchised now the yield of that
over 64 years now 2019 I think there was
a 21% single-parent rate in the black
community back then I might be wrong and
then once again these are the
subjectification but I think that
figures now over 70% and I just say well
you have a half a century to analyze the
data field this does not work we should
try something else that's the pragmatist
in me people on the Left I'm never will
never us though say no we just need
another 50 years to get there and you
think well what happens that 50 years of
it's 80% single you know I mean that I
get to a point where I go okay there's a
decision that has to be made here
there's no decisions that are those are
etched in stone over there sometimes the
you know people on both sides are etched
in the sand it's a little bit
bullshitting politics but they are
definitely etched in stone on around 10
of these things and that that lockstep
is tired to me so I don't like clogging
kind of like line dancing
I don't like liberal politics to me
and modern liberalism's like a nude
beach it sounds good till you get there
then there's a lot of cankles a lot of
misspelled tattoos it's in a second I'm
gonna ask you the final question I'm
gonna ask you for the best joke that you
have ever heard and the best joke that
you've ever told
but first if you want to hear Dennis
Miller's answer you actually have to be
a daily water subscriber to subscribe
head on over to daily wire comm click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation over there thanks so much
for stopping I really appreciate I'm
happy for you you're such a fine young
man I remember talking to you years ago
saying now that is uh you know what you
are you're a fine young man I don't done
don't know that they use that term
anymore and I don't mean to embarrass
you but you're a brilliant guy I talk to
people and they know you're brilliant
and when you get beyond brilliant you
find out the guy's not about being
brilliant but a nice young man I'm so
happy for you thank you so much I really
appreciate it good to see you
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis clever edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and hoola the
Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]